es un republicano devoto de un Distrito
conservador en medio de un estado
demócrata California
Kevin mccarthy de 57 años actual líder
de La minoría republicana tiene todos
los números para convertirse en el nuevo
presidente de la cámara de
representantes ha sido su objetivo desde
que llegó a Washington desde Bakersfield
en 2007 como congresista en caso de
Victoria opositora asumiría el tercer
cargo con más poder político de Estados
Unidos por detrás de la presidencia y la
vicepresidencia
Porque alguien quiere llegar a la
presidencia de la cámara por poder y
ambición
y francamente Kevin mccarthy ha sido
criticado por eso porque significa
abandonar ciertos principios principios
conservadores y republicanos a cambio de
la ambición de ganar
mccarthy casi consigue el martillo en
2015 cuando el republicano John Jenner
anunció su renuncia pero sus choques con
el Freedom kaucus el grupo
ultraconservador republicano en el
congreso se lo impidieron y el puesto
fue para Paul Ryan por eso recientemente
mccarthy se ha acercado a los miembros
del grupo ultraconservador incluido al
congresista por Ohio Jim Jordan a quien
ayudó a conseguir una codiciada posición
en el comité judicial de la cámara
mccarthy también fue uno de los primeros
en apoyar a Donald Trump de hecho
vinculó su suerte a la del expresidente
lo que resultó ser un arma de doble filo
y en 2020 se hizo eco de las acusaciones
infundadas de fraude en las elecciones
presidenciales
si me pregunta mi opinión creo que tiene
que verificarse legalmente cada voto
creo que hay que terminar todo lo
reconteos y que el resultado de cada
impugnación debe hacerse público
mccarthy también votó en contra de la
certificación de los resultados
electorales en Arizona y Pensilvania el
6 de enero de 2021 Aunque el republicano
condenó el asalto al Capitolio y
denunció el comportamiento de Donald
Trump semanas después fue amar a lago a
retractarse y a intentar recuperar el
aprecio del hombre que una vez le llamó
mi Kevin Trump todavía mantiene una gran
influencia sobre el partido republicano
y su poder puede dificultar la tarea del
nuevo presidente de la cámara que deberá
hacer equilibrios entre las distintas
facciones republicanas